I think Americans obsessed a lot over
celebrity.
But I think the thing that I've written
that you have to remember is a small
country.
It,
you know,
there's an expression that they use
saying that you punch above your weight,
which means you kind of play with the
big boys when you're not such a big boy.
So Britain,
you know,
tries to be more of a kind of world
figure than it may be is.
And so it kind of wants to do an America
does,
but it doesn't have as many celebrities.
It doesn't have,
um,
as many serious things to fill.
It's paper with papers with as America
does.
So it,
um,
it has this weird celebrity culture
filled with not that important
celebrities actually a lot of newspapers
that it has to sell and a lot of tablets
that are completely,
um,
hollywoodized.
I mean they're all about kind of crap
really.
And um,
and so,
so you do,
it's,
it's in the culture much more.
I mean,
there is a kind of lack of seriousness
and discourse there because of all that.
I think it's really brought down the
tone of a lot of the papers,
all this celebrity stuff.
I interviewed him,
um,
right before the dark knight was
rapping.
I think he was in his last couple of
months of filming.
And um,
he,
um,
was,
you know,
he,
first of all,
he's really good looking.
A lot of movie actors aren't good
looking at all when you meet them,
you know,
they're much smaller than you would hope
they were,
which is fine.
I've nothing against short people but,
but you know,
but you're disappointed because they
don't look the same as you want them to
look.
And he was like a big strapping,
you know,
Australian guy.
Um,
he clearly was really bright,
really creative,
very restless.
Um,
and you know,
but charming and charming and
intelligent and clearly having a tough
time with the filming.
And one of the things we talked about
was insomnia because I suffer from
insomnia as well.
So we were sort of trading tips,
so you know,
what kind of drugs to take and what kind
of,
you know,
techniques we used.
And He,
it kind of hauntingly said,
you know,
I've been taking ambien and I took one
last night and it didn't work.
So I took another one and then I only
slept for an hour.
And he said,
you know,
my mind is fizzing with this role.
I cannot get my mind to shut up.
And he didn't seem like he was,
you know,
on anything.
He just seemed like he was clearly
somebody who was one of those people
who,
who get so into his work that he
couldn't comment down those voices that
were all excited and fizzy.
And so I felt just so sad at the way he
died because clearly he was talking
about that.
And it was clearly was a mistake,
I think because he just couldn't get any
sleep.
And I know what that feels like.
Awful.
And so it was just shocking because he
seemed,
he was so full of life and so lovely.
And we talked about his daughter.
He was,
you know,
a little baby daughter.
He just loved her and it was just such a
waste.
It was so sad.
And again,
you know,
I just had,
would have had no idea.
And he certainly wasn't suicidal.
He was really full of life,
but it was so poignant.
He was living in a beautiful rented
house in London,
and it had,
I think three or four bedrooms.
They took me on a tour,
beautiful place,
and he showed me every single bed had
been,
it was all messy,
you know,
all the sheets were everywhere.
And he said,
cause last night I just couldn't sleep.
So I went from bed to bed hoping I could
fall asleep somewhere.
It's just so sad.
I'm just so sad.
And you know,
you wonder if someone had really kind of
taken him in hand and said,
you know,
let's,
this movie's hurting your health.
Let's try to work on this.
If he could have been helped,
who knows?
You know,
creative people are,
you can't really,
you don't really have answers,
do you?
Um,
you can't really know what makes them
tick.
Um,
but it was,
it was just,
it was a tragedy really.